j'ajoute qu'il faudrait une meilleure
formation et notamment une meilleure
orientation des jeunes qui trop nombreux
peut-être par méconnaissance des métiers
ou des possibilités de travail bon faire
des études qui ne déboucheront
mais ce gp bonjour je me présente
isabelle merron 30 ans j'ai un enfant à
charge et actuellement je suis au
chômage depuis le mois de juin j'ai été
licenciée économique
j'ai comme formation un bac d plus trois
années de beaux-arts étant depuis près
de trois ans engagé dans une entreprise
en tant que décoratrice puis a prévu la
crise et les événements je suis devenue
vendeuse puis remplaçant de vendeuse et
puis un jour on m'a dit au revoir
étant donné que je voyais bien que tout
ce qui est artistique et décoratif
n'était pas du tout le plein emploi
j'ai jugé bon de me former dans
l'informatique et de perfectionner mon
anglais
à l'heure actuelle j'ai trouvé une seule
façon de d'essayer de retravailler c'est
un contrat à temps choisi je représente
du vin et du champagne et je fais du
porte-à-porte
je suis allé de l'avant mais il ya un
moment où on a un petit peu peur face à
de telles responsabilités et où on a mon
avis pas angoissé donc ma question est
la suivante quel espoir pouvez vous
donner en français se trouvant dans ma
situation à l'heure actuelle c'est sans
doute la question la plus difficile
qu'on puisse poser un homme politique
mais il faut pas l'éluder parce que
c'est la question que se posent trois
millions et peut-être plus de françaises
et français et j'ai bien conscience que
personne ne peut comprendre l'angoissent
dont vous parlez s'il n'a pas vécu ce
que vous avez vécu je n'ai pas vécu et
donc je vous répondrais peut-être en
termes maladroit mais c'est notre
responsabilité à nous petits brigands
ont des responsabilités officielles
précisément que d'essayer de répondre
que peuvent faire les pouvoirs publics
que peut faire un gouvernement que
pourra faire demain président de la
république
d'abord proclamer avec toute la force de
sa conviction que ça n'est pas une
fatalité qui ne faut pas se résigner à
cette situation qu'on peut faire
autrement que certes les politiques
appliquées depuis dix ou quinze ans
n'ont pas permis de s'en sortir et qu'il
existe des solutions et que d'ailleurs
autour de nous d'allemagne en grand
bretagne aux états unis
d'autres pays font mieux que nous et là
je crois qu'il ya deux ou trois grandes
réformes engagées
la première réforme c'est celle de
l'organisation du temps de travail puis
la deuxième réforme fondamentale et
autres cas personnel il fait danser tout
particulièrement c'est la réforme de la
formation
trop de jeunes à l'heure actuelle sont
orientés entre guillemets ou plus
exactement pas orienté mais tout
simplement amener à des filières sans
avenir et sans débouchés et c'est un
problème explosif pour les prochaines
années car nous voyons bien que le
nombre d'étudiants augmente sans cesse à
l'université et que les propositions de
formations qu'on leur fait ne sont pas
assez diversifiée un exemple concret on
se réjouit beaucoup de voir qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'étudiants inscrits en
première année de médecine
cette année est de plus en plus
d'étudiants inscrits dans les filières
de formation au métier d'enseignant
je m'en réjouis pour ces deux
professions il y aura pas de place pour
tout le monde et on risque de se
retrouver au bout de deux ans en
situation d'échec qu'après le chômage et
l'anpe
il faut donc faire une réforme en
profondeur du premier cycle de
l'enseignement supérieur les deux
premières années quand on sort du lycée
avec un baccalauréat en poche pour
diversifier les formations pour les
professionnaliser davantage pour faire
des formations deux ou trois ans qui
conduisent à des métiers qui auront été
sélectionnés en liaison avec les
entreprises les régions bref tous ceux
qui sont sur le terrain
voilà quelques réformes importantes qui
me paraissent pouvoir changer la
situation
je suis femme de commerçants j'ai un
fils et j'habite strasbourg monsieur le
président vous attacher beaucoup
d'importance à l'aménagement du temps
des enfants pourquoi oui je suis attaché
effectivement beaucoup d'importance à
l'aménagement du temps des enfants parce
que je crois que c'est un c'est
l'exemple le plus achevé de ce qu'on
peut faire pour la france de demain
il s'agit de l'exemple de mesure où on
peut à la fois réglé un problème de
chômage et d'autre part lutter contre
l'échec scolaire
bon tout le monde sait aujourd'hui en
france que notre année scolaire est très
mal organisé nous avons de trop longues
vacances
nous avons de même une semaine de
travail qui est très bien organisée et
puis nous avons une journée de travail
alors qu' elle est proprement démentiel
puisque nous demandons six heures
parfois 6h30 de travail quotidien des
jeunes alors pensez aux gosses qui sont
en difficulté chez eux aux gosses dont
souvent des parents peuvent ne pas
savoir lire ou écrire des gosses dans
les parents peuvent être en situation
d'exclusion
comment voulez vous que ces gosses se
puisse réussir une scolarité alors le
système qu'il s'agirait de mettre en
place quel est il
il n'est de faire en sorte comme ça se
fait d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays
étrangers une semaine de travail de
saint jour où les enfants travaillent le
matin de 8h à 12h du lundi au vendredi
et l'après midi deux heures et demi
d'activités culturelles ou sportives
bien organisée planifiée sur l'année qui
leur permettent d'abord de mieux à
curgies t les connaissances
traditionnelles et d'autre part de
s'ouvrir sur la vie toutes les
évaluations qui ont été faites de ces
expériences montrent que les gosses sont
plus heureux ils ont plaisir à aller à
l'école
l'échec scolaire recul mais ce que vous
me dites me donne l'occasion de dire
quelque chose à quoi je crois très pro
on dément on critique souvent en france
l'école on critique l'éducation
nationale on critique les enseignants
ont dit oh là là c'était beaucoup mieux
avant etc
mais il faut se rendre compte dans quel
contexte ils évoluent jamais les
enseignants n'ont eu autant de
difficultés
l'école elle n'a jamais été aussi bonne
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le contexte social
dans lequel elle travaille qui s'est
dégradée et elle en subit forcément le
contrecoup elle ne peut faire l'école
qu'avec ce qu'on lui envoie alors
changeons le contexte social
battons-nous contre le chômage et
l'exclusion et vous verrez que l'école
montrera sa capacité de performance sans
grande difficulté
je pense que dans le cadre d'une
véritable relation entre l'université
notamment et les milieux professionnels
et régionaux une information claire
disons tout jeune voilà les métiers qui
ont un avenir et ceux qui ne l'ont pas
vous permettrait à moins de jeunes de
s'égarer
et puis il nous faut un statut nouveau
de l'étudiant les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
ont besoin d'eux quand ils sont dans
cette période de formation universitaire
ou après le baccalauréat ont envie
d'entrer dans la vie dont on a envie
d'être un peu libre
il leur faut un statut qui organise
cette liberté et qui leur permet aussi
le vivre et tout le système des bourses
des allocations tout ça doit être
profondément revue les crédits devront
être augmentés et en même temps un vrai
statut de l'étudiant et de l'étudiante
ils leur permettent de d'entrer dans la
vie de d'étudiants dans des conditions
convenables
moi je pense d'abord aux familles très
modestes c'est ça le statut d'étudiant
donné à tous les étudiants quelle que
soit leur origine et surtout plus
modeste les moyens d'entrer dans cette
vie dans des conditions dignes et
convenable
je m'appelle aurélie tardieu j'ai 17 ans
et je suis élève en terminale littéraire
au lycée carnot
jacques chirac a proposé un référendum
sur l'éducation
s'il était élu en quoi consiste-t-il le
référendum doit consister à demander aux
français s'ils approuvent par oui ou par
non
un projet de loi puisque on vote non pas
simplement sur une question comme ça en
l'air on vote sur un texte législatif
ce projet de loi qui doit être préparée
par un vaste débat national qui doit
durer plusieurs mois avant le référendum
ce projet doit devrait comporter
essentiellement trois questions première
question les rythmes scolaires
c'est à dire le matin les enseignements
fondamentaux l'après midi sports arts
culture deuxième
la deuxième question c'est la réforme de
la formation des maîtres et notamment
pour leur permettre de mieux apprendre
aux enfants tout ce qui est fondamental
c'est à dire en fait la maîtrise du
langage la maîtrise de la communication
du dialogue avec autrui
et enfin la troisième question c'est
celle naturellement de l'organisation
c'est à dire plus d'autonomie et plus de
responsabilité pour les établissements
d'enseignement et pour les enseignants
il faut d'abord reconnaître la famille
comme un élément essentiel du dynamisme
d'une société ce qu'elle est et comme un
élément fondamental de la solidarité la
convivialité de la société donc de sa
fin
choix qu'il faut bien s'entendre sur la
place des jeunes dans notre société
je crois que les jeunes ne sont pas à
part ne doivent pas êtres à part ils
sont une part de la nation il n'y a pas
à la limite de problèmes jeunes
spécifiques par exemple je ne crois pas
aux actions particulières contre le
chômage des jeunes
non il y a des aspects concernant plus
particulièrement les jeunes de problèmes
qui sont des problèmes de toute la
nation
il en va ainsi en particulier de ce que
sont les les deux craintes les deux
angoisses principal des jeunes savoir le
chômage bien sûr et le sida d'autre part
ça ne concerne pas que les jeunes
mais les jeunes sont marqués toute cette
génération de jeunes est marqué par
l'existence par la concomitance de ces
deux phénomènes
c'est pourquoi dans son discours à la
jeunesse à bercy discours qui a eu un
grand retentissement jacques chirac a
fait de la lutte contre le sida de la
lutte contre le chômage s'adressant aux
jeunes une double priorité de son
septennat
enfin si vous aviez a résumé le
programme de jacques chirac pour la
culture et l'éducation que diriez vous
je dirais que le premier point le plus
important c'est que jacques chirac a dit
je considère que dans notre république
le chef de l'état est responsable des
intérêts du pays en matière de culture
et d'éducation
ça c'est tout à fait essentiel que ça
veut dire que son engagement personnel
et total dans ces domaines de
l'éducation et de la culture
et puis ensuite je crois que le maître
mot c'est naturellement démocratie et
égalité égalité des chances pour
l'enseignement égalité des chances pour
la culture c'est à dire que l'école soit
un instrument de promotion en instrument
d'intégration républicaine pour tous et
la culture c'est exactement la même
chose la culture pour tous partout donc
lutter contre toutes les inégalités
d'accès aux richesses de l'art et de la
culture voilà le maître mot je crois
l'égalité des chances